in other news Sean Spicer I don't know
exactly how to start this because of how
absurd it was so let's start by
listening to what Sean Spicer actually
said in his press conference on
yesterday you look we didn't use
chemical weapons in World War two you
know you had a you know someone is
despicable as Hitler who didn't even
sink to the 22 using chemical weapons so
you have to appear Russia ask yourself
is this a country that you in a regime
that you want to align yourself with you
have previously signed on your
international agreements rightfully
acknowledging that the use of chemical
weapons should be out of balance by
every country okay Pat I think anyone
who has spent any time in school
whatsoever understands that Hitler used
chemical weapons to kill millions of
people well luckily the reporter was
there to give him a chance to clarify I
but at the clarification actually he
made a situation worse let's listen to
the clarification well Hitler didn't
even think the level of using chemical
weapons what did you mean by that I
think when you come to sarin gas there
was no he was not using the gas on his
own people the same way that a shot is
doing I mean there was clearly I
understand a foot thing hi thank you I
appreciate that there was not in the in
the he brought him into the two to the
Holocaust Center and I understand that
what I was saying in the way that the
Assad used them where he went into town
dropped him down to innocent into the
middle of town it was brought so the use
of it I appreciate the clarification
there that was not the intent so the
clarification actually doubles down on
trying to draw a difference without a
distinction and this this is okay so
let's start here with the facts at the
height of the killing a towel switch
about six thousand Jews were killed
daily using chemical using chemical
weapons and gas showers he tried to
shown spice you try to draw a
distinction to say well aside our Hitler
didn't bomb people in their own town
that's actually not true according to
yada Yad Vashem dot org as reported by
vox com nazis actually did attack people
in their hometown using vans gas vans
and using signed I'm sorry not cyanide
in this case but carbon monoxide to kill
upwards of seven hundred thousand people
in their own home so this is 2 for 2
that Sean Spicer is completely
historically wrong right and it just
violates the first rule of politics
yeses don't make comparisons to the
Nazis and Hitler because oftentimes it's
just seen as insensitive or there's no
direct link there or it's just
completely unwarranted it reminds me of
when Jeb Bush would was asked if you
would go back in time and kill baby
Hitler regardless of how you answer that
question you're going to look bad yeah I
mean absolutely and it's it's it's
disturbing because this is the press
secretary this is the the person that's
charged with being the lead communicator
for the most powerful office in the in
the entire world and he is incapable of
communicating a thought without selling
it in this fashion we're not not only
making historical inaccurate statement
statements but making offensive highly
offensive statements of the highest
order the highest magnitude how do you
get this far in politics and in this
type of position and you're completely
inept and incompetent and I really don't
think there was any malice behind what
he said there I knew but you know words
matter especially when you're the White
House press secretary I mean but he made
it even worse he had to come back later
on on CNN and apologize yet again and I
don't know if you have decorative okay
let's listen to all mostly in it all I
was obviously trying to make a point
about the heinous acts an decided made
against his own people last week using
chemical weapons and gas and frankly I
mistakenly used an inappropriate and
insensitive reference to the Holocaust
for which frankly there's no there is no
no no comparison and for that i
apologize it was a mistake to do that
and and you know I appreciate the
director Panetta comments and we'll keep
those in mind so Sean Spicer has
demonstrated Godwin's law and governs
law is basically online online arguments
the longer you talk about something
the more likely someone is going to
compare you to Hitler that he has
violated the first rule of politics as
well as demonstrated perfectly Godwin's
law this is what happens when you try to
be hyperbolic and you tried to make a
distinction without a difference Sean
Spicer I'm not sure how he is the press
secretary when he's not capable of
communicating effect without being
historically inaccurate and grossly
offensive wait before you go on to the
next video because of the YouTube
advertiser boycott ads aren't playing on
our YouTube channel which means we are
no longer making any money from these
videos please help us fight back and
replace the lost revenue so that the
show can stay on exactly as it has been
uninterruptedly whatever you can even a
dollar per month at patreon.com slash
david pakman show we need your help